I want to show the this slide which
shows some of the Nobel prize-winning of
partnerships they range from us we're
the longest ones 39 years you know it's
not fair Corey and Corey were married to
each other I think the primary benefit
of the vent for us is the ability of our
trainees to witness firsthand an
individual who is essentially an
inspiration to all of us his example of
collaboration that he showed and
emphasizing that came out so naturally
in his entire talk if I'm speaking and
Joe is in the audience he should all
notice that he's never drinking water
he really made it seem that it was
possible and something that I'll think
about even more and hopefully one day
could engage in because it clearly has
so much potential for creating wonderful
science and really solving major
problems you know it is not uncommon for
two people to work together to produce
the work that is recognized by a Nobel
Prize and and I I just urge you all to
think about it I'm glad that you're here
because I think that young students and
trainees it's it's really helpful for us
to have role models and I think you know
we learn a lot from your story and Joe
story we couldn't have predicted any of
this and I and I have to say that we
didn't go into it with the idea that
somehow if we solve this problem we're
going to cure a disease we just it was
just curiosity one of the very important
lessons that Mike teaches us is that a
dedication and commitment always win the
day michael is a tremendous scientist
with a great wealth of knowledge and he
is he shared that knowledge over the the
last two days during the event both at
the University of Pennsylvania here at
the wall meets the site this is the
feedback mechanism that allows cells to
acquire cholesterol when they need it
and to turn off the sources of
cholesterol when they don't need it and
that's what Joe and I basically shared
the nobel prize for this is an
opportunity to get people exposed to the
the what and the why it a little bit
more depth to emphasize that this is why
we invest in science this is why we
invest in research in order to really
get the very important innovations I do
believe that you need to do it in
partnership academics need the
pharmaceutical companies because they're
going to produce the medicines that are
going to help our patients farmer needs
academic physicians because they
understand
than anybody what we've done over the
our whole career is is to just start
with something and then dig deeper and
deeper and deeper not just don't be
satisfied with one observation well this
is the the best that science gets this
is high-quality terrific work and from
basic research to show that out of this
came way saving medicines a wonderful
you know portrayal of science and what
we do I'm eternally grateful to this
university for making it possible for me
to have the kind of fun that I've had
over the last 39 years I wish all of you
the same kind of luck thank you very
much